dark matter is gravitating it's matter
it's just not made of ordinary atoms
that we understand and know likely
formed very early in that in the
universe dark energy on the other hand
we have no idea what it is we know what
it does Hubble discovered in 1929 that
the Universe was expanding that the
distances between galaxies was
increasing with time and the farther a
Galaxy was away from us the faster it
seems to be hurtling away from us right
but then in 1998 so this is early recent
we discovered that not only is do you
have an expansion but the universe is
actually accelerating expansion and as
we all know right if something's
accelerating you have to provide energy
or you drive your car or whatever you
have to press the gas pedal to
accelerate so dark energy is giving us
that gas
pedal